Okay, so why virtualization in
hypervisor may give you better security,
we're going to get back to the third
requirement that we have for
a trusted computing base,
which was getting it right or
having the correctness property.
And correctness is really important
because compromise of that trusted
computing base means attacker
has access to everything.
Remember our keys to the kingdom
statement that we had before?
You compromise the operating system,
you gain access to all the physical
resources, every memory page, every
block on the disk, whatever else is
coming in out of this machine and so on.
So compromise off of TCB
is really bad and so
we don't want that and that's why we
want the correctness requirement.
Unfortunately getting
the trusted computing base,
meeting this correctness
requirement is extremely hard.
Operating systems are complex,
there's all kind of concurrency,
resource management, handling,
managing devices or dealing with
devices that we have lots of them and
things like that makes it complex.
And we know complex is not good for
security or for correctness.
So one thing you can do is make
the trusted computing base smaller.
Hopefully, if it's smaller and
simpler, then you have a better
change of getting it correct.
So the third requirement of a TCB.
You can see the connection
with virtualization.
Hopefully, the hypervisor is a lot
smaller than the operating system.
Because all it should do is
partition the physical resources
across the various virtual machines.
And a lot of the guest management
of how those resources get used by
the applications can be done
by the guest operating system.
The details right in the main point
to take away from here is that
hypervisor could be smaller and simpler.
And if that is true then securely or
having correctness of that, for
that obviously going to quote
it securely, is important with
the operating system because it
gives you access to everything.
It's written in languages and not type
set, so keeping that program smaller and
simpler is going to help
you get it right and
have that correctness requirement
that we're talking about.
So, with a hypervisor,
you may have a better chance than
a full fledged operating system.